hi uh this is uh shivital devi and
i'm here to uh you know start off
our alexa speech lightning talk i'd like
to give a quick
round of introductions to my colleagues
and then
we'll jump right into the talk um
yeah my name is shiva taldemy i'm a
director in applied science in
alexa i've been there for more than
seven years and it's been a super fun
ride
to see alexa launch and grow with
millions of customers across the globe
and i've had the pleasure of working
with some of the colleagues who
present you today for many years and
they made foundational contributions to
alexa
following me would be arya astro who is
a senior principal
scientist in speech recognition um
and uh then he'll be followed by andrew
brenn
who works in text to speech uh based out
of cambridge uk
and uh this will be followed by chao
wang who's a senior manager in applied
science
uh and her team develops uh several of
the technologies that go into
acoustic event detection as well as
sentiment analysis
and also we have you know hundreds of
other engineers and scientists who have
directly contributed to the work
that you'll be seeing here as well as to
alexa in general
with that let's directly dive into waker
the vast majority of alexa devices are
hands-free which means that
we want to enable users to be able to
interact with these conversational ai
systems
without having to touch the screen or
touch the device
and to be able to talk to the devices
from a distance
what's called far field and speech
recognition
and one of the fundamental challenges
here is to determine
accurately when the user is trying to
initiate interactions with alexa
and that's where wakewood comes in um
to paraphrase to olympian dictum we want
wakeword to be better faster and smaller
the overarching goal is to have a high
correct detection rate that is we should
be able to detect accurately whenever
the user wants to initiate interaction
with alexa with near zero false
positives
that is we do not want to wake up the
device when no one is trying to talk to
the device
i'll just go through quickly through
some of the challenges
first and foremost privacy is paramount
we want to make sure that
false accepts are low uh you know
customer trust us and buy these devices
and bring in
and bring them into their households and
our
highest priority is to make sure that we
live up to those
that trust and customer expectation
because this is a far-field device we
have low signal to noise ratio
there's a lot of noise coming in let's
say from
background within the house like kitchen
noise and also from outside for instance
street noise reverberation
because you could have typically you
have
the sound bouncing of the walls and
other surfaces in the room and coming to
the microphones
in addition to the direct sound coming
from
the user's mouth to the microphones you
have competing speech
i have two young kids and they talk all
the time while i'm trying to interact
with alexa
and sometimes they actually win over me
in terms of the music they play
and you also have to be able to interact
with the device when the device is
outputting sound for instance if the
users want to change
a song or they want to skip a song we
need to be able to
wake up the device during those bargain
interactions as well
as with any speech recognition problem
you know there are
pronunciation differences also notice
that
the false accepts come from typically
come from background speech
and for households depending upon their
language
the false accepts could be very
different from let's say my household
where
we speak a couple of indian languages
versus let's say you know some other
households with native americans
um we need to
ensure that the backward detection is of
high accuracy and also low latency
what we have observed is if you
introduce several seconds worth of
latency let's say five ten seconds worth
of latency
it looks like as good as bad as a false
reject so we need to make sure that we
are able to wake up the device within a
few hundred milliseconds
of the user saying the waker and all
this has to be done
under very stringent cpu and memory
constraints
in addition this is a very
interesting machine learning problem
because of the extremely skewed labels
um the device is trying to detect the
wake word
24 7 and the vast majority of the time
no liquid is being uttered and
typically you know you might have a few
hundred times that the users interact
with the device in a week
so it's very skewed on the other hand in
the cloud
you have far more positive samples
compared to
negative samples or false accepts so you
have a far more true accepts compared to
false accepts and we have to be able to
train the
models uh while taking into account this
extreme skewing labels
now i'm going to just describe at a high
level what happens during a detection so
you have the
true wake code instances which are being
uttered every once in a while by the
user
you have all other sound events for
instance you know
doors closing kitchen noises as well as
background speech
where you know people are talking among
themselves or there is a tv
or some other media going on in the
background on the device we need to be
able to correctly reject all these other
background
speech and sounds while correctly
detecting the
true waypoint instances when the device
hypothesizes that there is a wake word
in the audio
then we call it an on device accept at
that point the device lights up
we open an audio stream to the cloud
where we perform a second level of
verification
to determine if there is liquid in the
audio or not
um the main reason is that on in the
cloud
we have much more compute resources and
then uh
we can also uh determine uh based on
some other context whether there's a
liquid in the audio or not
once the cloud site verification also
determines that indeed there is liquid
in the audio
then downstream systems kick in like for
example natural language understanding
and other alexa responses
and actions
over the last one and a half years we
have shifted to
a different model architecture using
convolutional neural networks
here we use convolutional filters to
extract features from the acoustic
features
and then these are processed through
a few layers of convolutional networks
and then
through a fully connected neural network
and this is applied at the level of a
audio segment of almost at the word
level
and the advantage you get is that you
can
directly model a bunch of uh both
spectral and temporal context
to get more accurate detections as
is shown in one of these details where
we can see that compared to
the dna hmm system which is the blue
line
um we see a lower
false rejection rate as well as over
false excess with the cnn
and now we have you know propagated cnns
across our devices
across bakewards as well as vocals
now i'm going to walk you through a
sequence of papers that we're presenting
at interspeech
i do hope that you get a chance to talk
directly with the scientists
um to get more details and also to spur
interaction and collaboration the first
paper
is on what's called gain in variant
modeling
notice that we have 20 plus lxr devices
just manufactured within amazon
and we have many many more avs devices
each of this device has its own
microphone array
acoustic characteristics signal
processing in terms of beam forming echo
cancellation
so the audio front end introduces
variation in the audio gain which is
being input into the vacuum detector
and what we found was that this
variability in the audio gain
actually changes the model behavior for
instance
at the bottom right you can see some of
the dead curves where
if a different audio gain the dead curve
itself can shift
or even if it doesn't shift the
operating point on the dead curve can
shift
and the paper presents some features
that we developed
these are based on differentials of log
filter bank
energy delta lfbe and we show that
we can compute them within the cnn model
itself
and with these features we can actually
reduce some of the variability
across these devices and also
across the microphone gain
and this actually helps us
anticipate what kind of false accepts
and false rejects that we want
the on device detection to have
the next paper talks about metadata
aware
end-to-end keyword spotting so here
notice that in our devices they could be
many different states
so for instance it could be playing
music at different
volume levels you could have alarm you
could have even time of day
when typically the usage patterns are
different
and what we have observed is that
accounting for this the state of the
device helps
significantly in improving model
accuracy
where rather than building one model
with one operating point for all types
of
device and usage conditions can we
automatically adjust the model behavior
to these different conditions
this particular paper you know covers
one of them it focuses on the playback
conditions so
is the device playing sound or not and
what we show is that by accounting for
these conditions we are able to improve
accuracy
the specific approach we show
is where we compute a fixed length
embedding of the device state
and then we modulate the feature maps
the convolutional feature maps
uh through uh batch normalization
and we show that with this we are able
to reduce the false rejection rate by
about
14 percent relative while
maintaining false accepts
next one is uh so now shifting here so
till now the the previous two papers
were on
on device and now i'm going to talk
about cloud site verification aspect
um so here as you
saw recently we we launched hey samuel
as a wake word so that
you can talk to samuel jackson and the
team is by the way super excited about
it
so there um what we wanted to
uh examine if it is possible to verify
the presence or absence of a wake word
in audio
independent of the wake code itself so
is there
uh some context in the audio
corresponding to the wake word
and the sound surrounding it
uh to be for us to be able to verify
if there is a wakeword in the audio
uh independent of whether the record was
alexa or echo or amazon or
samuel um the advantage is that
we have very uh you know uh very large
amounts of data for alexa but we have
orders of magnitude lesser
amount of data for uh amazon echo
computer and for sure for hay samuel
which
launched recently so is it possible to
learn something
from these other high volume vapors that
we can apply to these low volume liquids
and again you know we see that yes
indeed you know
there is some sort of some specific
context in terms of how people pause uh
and the emphasis they use and the tone
they use
uh which can be used to verify
uh the waker and the idea is to use this
in conjunction with let's say a more
backward specific model
uh to improve accuracy
the fourth paper uh i talk about
is focusing on using the recurrent
neural architecture
combined with the convolutional neural
networks so it's
crnns and here
the main intuition is that when there is
misalignment
in where the wake would is in the audio
segment
then cnns can be prone to
this misalignment in the sense that they
could
have more errors whereas with the
recurrent
architecture it provides this robustness
to where the wake word
and the sub the phones within the wake
word
are present in the audio and we have
some baseline experiments
which show that some of this robustness
can be achieved
with larger receptive fields as well
within a cnn
but with crn this can be done much more
efficiently
and with a smaller number of model
parameters
and just to highlight that the work is
not done
in no sense of the word um you know
there is continued significant
investment in improving accuracy
we recently had prime day where we sold
millions of devices
and we continued to focus on uh
reducing false accepts um improving
recall
um achieving parity across locales
also uh we recently launched new
wakehouse
and that throws up very interesting
research challenges
in terms of how to improve accuracy with
minuscule amounts of data
and also we're not impacting existing
vehicles
with that i'd like to hand off to my
colleague
arya rashtro who will cover automatic
speech recognition asr
thank you